you know that there is nothing going on
with me in jazz that stuff that is all
in the past there's nothing to do with
jazz what better way to emotionally
recover from a breakup than
understanding what went wrong we'll be
chatting about 15 of your favorite
Disney Channel couples who devastatingly
entered splitsville before our very eyes
and talking through the unfortunate
events leading to their breakups
hopefully these lessons will not only
offer some closure but also shed some
light on your own relationships anyway I
was madly in love with him and out of
the blue he dumped me for Kim Brooks
they may have been sailing on the high
sea but this couple had us on a roller
coaster during all three seasons of the
suite life on deck after crushing hard
on Bailey Cody went to great lengths to
grab her interest these two made it
official at the end of season one and
found themselves losing it all by the
end of season two the couple decided to
call it quits when they realized their
negative emotions have gotten the better
of them and their relationship the worst
part this all happened in the most
romantic place on earth Paris then it's
over
[Music]
nothing pained us more than to see this
long-awaited love crumble before our
very eyes
after only a handful of months together
live in Holden succumb to the pressure
of the media an intrusive paparazzi in
the infamous episode scooped a rooney
after Matias lived to cover for her to
conceal her new relationship with Josh
and to protect Dickies feelings Liv
agrees and does incorrect reporters when
the news breaks this pained Holden who
felt like the decision came at the
expense of his own feelings after their
tearful breakup the two can't stop
thinking about each other and attempt to
rekindle towards the end of the episode
this reminded us that even when there's
a slight bump in the road love overcomes
all I feel bad about how everything came
out I really do to live in Holden
weren't the only couple that traveled
through splitsville during the live in
Mattie series onigen off against 40
couple Maddie and diggie had our hearts
in knots every time one of the pair left
town
ultimately leaving the fate of their
relationship unknown although
long-distance mostly worked for them the
real trouble in their relationship came
when they were reunited they had grown
out of touch with how to be around each
other due to the distance which made it
tough for them to relate while we were
upset to see the turmoil in their
relationship we got to see how a
different relationships take on
different formats and what matters most
is that both people are happy life
wasn't always so sweet on deck for the
Martin brothers especially zagged having
met who he believed to be his soul mate
while working at the juice bar my Anzac
began to grow beside each other and as
individuals as their relationship
progressed for Zach we saw how much Maya
helped him mature and cheap him into a
character we could relate to on the cusp
of being in love Maya gets accepted to
the Peace Corps in Chad Africa
Zach tries to convince Maya that they
should stay together but unfortunately
Maya declines stating that the distance
would be too difficult to navigate the
moment when Zach confesses that the last
three months were a waste our hearts
dropped we just hope Zach realizes that
even in situations that seem wasted
there is always something to learn don't
touch me I can't believe I wish the best
three months of my life on you Alex and
Mason's breakup in season 3 put a spell
on us but not in a good way after
confessing his love for Juliet right in
front of Alex we were heartbroken and
left wondering how anyone could be so
cruel luckily Alex's mom was there to
comfort her delivering the line all of
us would benefit from your one broken
heart closer to one happily ever after
well accidents surely happened most of
us are human and not wizards or
werewolves this devastating break
offered as a lesson in the power of
forgiving and forgetting in order to
mend your own heart
from eating randomly at a New Year's Eve
party to spending a whole semester
flirting with each other secretly we
were on the edge of our seats hoping
that Gabriela and Troy would recognize
their love for each other and
official in the first High School
Musical flick the sequel fulfilled our
dreams immediately showing Troy and
Gabriella together and appearing to be
more infatuated with one another
that is until Shar Peis interference and
Troy's resulting change in character
causes Gabriella to call things off
gotta go my own way was the break-up
anthem we hated to love and it left us
wondering why these Wildcats couldn't
work it out we aren't left asking
questions for too long as they come back
together to perform a new song in the
talent show settling their love and our
queasy stomachs here's to the future mr.
right now Raven Baxter and Devin
Carter's relationship was one that had
us cheering in the early 2000s after
competing to get his attention Deven
chooses Raven over her nemesis
commencing their lengthy and loving
relationship over two seasons everything
is solid between them until Devin's dad
gets married and moves the family to
Seattle we were heartbroken seeing Raven
at the wedding ceremony watching Devin
walk out the door and away from her
permanently while they tried to keep up
with a long-distance relationship the
timing just isn't right between them and
they grow apart
years later they end up coming back into
each other's lives to marry as we got to
witness here when love is meant to
happen not even distance can stop it I'm
glad that you didn't go to the prom with
someone else
I wouldn't want to go to the prom with
anyone else but you breakups make ups
and werewolves oh my we thought nothing
could come between this human zombie
power couple Addison and Zed until an
unfortunate promposal incident results
in cute werewolves coming to town
mistaking Addison's friendliness with
the newcomers for flirting Zedd gets
jealous and walks out on her the pain
doesn't stop there as we watch
Addison debate becoming a werewolf and
trading in Seabrook for the community
den
luckily Zedd comes to his senses and
realizes Addison's intentions are pure
and we watch them help the werewolves
together sometimes our individual
battles are hard to deal with on our own
and that's why we need to surround
ourselves with people or monsters who
want to help us
way to go Zed use those zombie muscles
mirror mirror on the wall what's the
saddest fairytale breakup of them all
now and Benz of course how did this
enchanted relationship go from love at
first sight to cursed after discovering
mal is still using spells to make life
easier
an argument breaks out between them over
a conjured meal and mal rejects Ben's
signet ring all hope seems to be lost
until Ben gets kidnapped knowing deep
down that she loves him mal chases after
uma and does everything she can to set
him free with every hurdle we encounter
in life it's always easier to take the
easy way but learning from the
dedication of Ben and Mau to help each
other we're reminded that we can conquer
anything with love by our side I love
you I've always loved you Asli how does
singing for joy when they finally got
together following their serendipitous
meet at the record store their
flirtations continued on and off with
Allie being the first to tell Austin how
she felt we were hoping this couple
would overcome the obstacles with their
careers but Allie decided it would be
too much trouble to dodge the media and
instead suggest they should be friends
they leave us with hope after agreeing
to get back together when the time is
right and they're both ready sometimes
things don't always work out in the
timeline we hoped but if they're meant
to happen they often do of all the
breakups on this list
none of them caused us the same amount
of dizziness as Spencer and Teddy's
ain't good luck charlie
throughout this series it was difficult
for us to keep up with whether they were
together or apart in season one
Teddy discovered Spencer had been
cheating on her but are reunited shortly
after when Teddy can't deny her feelings
for him we're happy they finally decided
on being with each other but it
definitely made us wonder if the drama
was worth it sometimes it's better to
let things go rather than force it and
if you ever
hurt my little girl okay keeping her
popstar life a secret wasn't the only
difficult thing Miley had to face
throughout the Hannah Montana series
caught in a love triangle between Jessi
and Jake we were devastated when Miley
chose Jake over Jessi even after working
on a duet titled he could be the one
when Jessi reappeared in season four it
Reese parked the hope in our hearts the
couple became official and spent the
rest of the series as girlfriend and
boyfriend ain't it true that when you
love something you need to let it go and
if it comes back to you then it was
meant to be
Wow I really want to tell you get more
beautiful every time I see you the
flirtatious relationship we got to see
develop between sunny and Chad or Chani
was exciting at first until it cost them
their relationship after so random is
chosen for the best tween show Chad
makes it his mission to set things right
between him and sunny
unfortunately setting things right then
revealing that there was a miscount
making so random the losers after all
sunny is upset that Chad let his
competitiveness get in the way of their
love and decides to end it we were
heartbroken to see them split but
understood that that sort of rivalry
just wasn't healthy so don't do this
Chad there are no second chances
Jan D and E Beck Mac Beck whichever of
these nicknames you were shipping the
unfortunately didn't last for a long
after crushing on Jonah for what felt
like forever the pair finally called it
official and made our heart skip a beat
we knew how much Andy cared for Jonah so
we were happy when he saw this too
unfortunately a stint at frisbee camp
gave Andy enough time to see how much
she was actually just building up their
relationship when Jonah returns the pair
decide that their relationship is less
on the romantic side and decided to stay
friends we can't argue with this
decision sometimes things don't work out
even when you want them to what ones
that the one we're one of us like
somebody else
right life at the lodge isn't as
easygoing as you might think it would be
when sky moves from the big city to live
with her dad in rural Ireland she gets a
lot more than she bargained for when
they take over ownership of a local
hotel in addition to helping her dad
build up the business sky almost
immediately finds herself in a lover's
quarrel with two of the locals pretend
dating jealousy miscommunication and
kissing behind the back makes it
difficult for Sky to choose who to enter
a relationship with ultimately Shaun
grows tired of the drama and decides to
end things between the two baby friends
if you're feeling down you're not alone
but before you grab the ice cream and
stream Joni Mitchell remember that life
is always changing and nothing is for
certain all things happen for a reason
and the lessons we learn only make us
stronger
[Music]
you
[Music]